on n'attendra pas la fin du reportage
pour vous dévoiler la sombre vérité
ça se peut qu'on trouve des bactéries
éducatrices de contamination fécale
c'est-à-dire des germes qu'on retrouve
habituellement dans les toilettes
donc numéro 1 ça a commencé il y a
quelques temps si c'est la bonne
Guinée ça ça doit bien garder des
bactéries on s'est demandé ce qui se
cachait dans 12 des lavettes éponges ou
guenilles des collègues de l'épicerie
ici là il y a une curiosité ah ça
dépendances en silicone
tous les supervision de chaque tour et
de Marie-José Giroux des étudiants du
Collège de maison neuve ont
minutieusement analysé nos 12
échantillons donc on a pris
l'échantillon puis on l'a mis dans une
solution stérile volume pressible pour
obtenir la première dilution le mettre
en contact avec les milieux de culture
spécifiques ont été préparés à l'avance
toute cette manipulation a été réalisée
dans des conditions aseptiques
si des milliards de bactéries se
trouvent dans nos échantillons les
experts se sont concentrés à dénombrer
des levures moisissures quelque sorte de
bactéries et des coliformes comme le
E-coli
et les études qui ont été faites que des
plusieurs dizaines de milliards de
bactéries qui sont heureusement pour la
plupart inoffensives pour l'être humain
selon le président de l'association des
microbiologistes du Québec la plupart
des bactéries sont inoffensives mais
certaines sont potentiellement
pathogènes c'est-à-dire qu'elles sont
porteuses de maladies prenez par exemple
on est vraiment malchanceux on rentre à
la compta avec une bactérie donc on lave
on rince moins bien la vaisselle et on
se contamine avec un eucoli qui devient
exemple rester caché qu'on a nettoyé le
sang on s'est évident que on peut avoir
une infection pourrait même parler de
maladies du hamburger qui peut emmener à
des fièvres des diarrhées et bon tu es
très rare que quand même la mort
si votre prochaine visite qu'on va faire
aussitôt qu'on aura terminé toute
l'étape dans ce lancement on va déposer
ces différents échantillons là à des
températures spécifiques pour une
période d'incubation les cas graves sont
rares mais les chercheurs s'attendent à
ce que les 12 échantillons soient tout
de même un réservoir de micro-organismes
nés dans notre maison viande crue fruits
trop mûres même à laver pour arriver à
ses conclusions une dernière étape
laissez le temps ou liquide d'analyse
d'incuber au moins 48 heures avant de
tout nous révéler les bactéries amener
humides donc c'est sûr que plus l'éponge
est sec plus on diminue la prolifération
des bactéries et de plusieurs en
survivent pas
avec les fameuses éponges et qui sont
très longues à sécher parce que l'éponge
retient l'eau
on est de retour au laboratoire suite et
fin des analyses on va enfin savoir ce
que les experts ont trouvé dans nos
torchons et nos éponges ça formait de
bactéries
toutes les épaules qui ont été analysées
ont présenté un compte de colonie
recherché qui était largement au-dessus
des normes acceptables
pour ces deux échantillons on a eu même
la misère à dénombrer la quantité de
colonies
parce que lui il absorbe pas d'eau il
retient pas d'eau celle-ci est la plus
problématique
due à l'éponge en tant que telle
lorsqu'on regarde ça au microscope ou
juste à la loupe vous allez voir ici
très poreux donc les bactéries l'eau
rentre dedans reste en prisonnier je
dirais cette mort à récurer là même
c'est des très
utile facile d'utilisation et fait très
bien sa job et selon moi mais on pire
choix
[Musique]
pour moi un microbiologiquement parlant
bactériologiquement parlant c'est mon
premier choix pour récurer et nettoyer
la vaisselle considérant que les
bactéries peuvent difficilement y
adhérer dans les épaules on a trouvé
presque de toute son vrai jardin
zoologique microbiologique
on les nettoie seulement on les lave
c'est pas assez il faut aussi les
désinfecter pour être sûr que on
recommence pas en recontamination
surtout avec des bactéries d'origine
fécales qui peuvent provoquer des
gastro-entériques pour réduire les
bactéries au maximum on peut glisser
notre éponge humide deux minutes au
micro-ondes la passer au lave-vaisselle
ou encore à la laveuse avec eau chaude
savon et eau de javel on peut aussi la
faire tremper dans de l'eau très chaude
avec un produit désinfectant pendant au
moins 15 minutes
[Musique]
c'est celui qui coûte le moins cher
sinon c'est l'oxygénée c'est le vinaigre
le vinaigre son excellent désinfectant
faut noter que la majorité des éponges
analysées étaient stockée après
utilisation au niveau de levier
de cuisine c'est un endroit qui est par
excellence déjà pollué déjà contaminé
puis qui est aussi exposé à la présence
d'une grande humidité
torchon guillemet va accumuler moins de
bactéries à la longue qu'une fameuse
éponge car c'est l'eau mais les
bactéries oui même dans un torchon sec
vont quand même rester présente et pour
la plupart rester vivant donc on lave on
désinfecte et pour le reste et bien les
bactéries sont partout il faut
simplement apprendre à cohabiter avec
elle
[Musique]